Je ne renie pas mon passé.
Ça, c'est sûr.
Je veux dire :
je suis même consciente
que c'est ce qui fait
ce que je suis maintenant.
Si je suis devant vous
avec ce voile
et que j'accepte de parler
de ma quête
ou d'un cheminement,
c'est, je pense, aussi
parce que j'ai été Diam's,
parce que les gens
m'ont connue,
parce que les gens ont connu
une partie de l'histoire, que...
Je pense que les gens
qui m'ont vraiment aimée,
ils ont décelé
des souffrances,
déjà à l'époque.
Et il y en a plein
qui disent :
on s'est toujours demandé
comment ça se terminerait.
Est-ce que tu allais trouver
des réponses
à tes questions
ou est-ce que tu allais
te foutre en l'air, en fait ?
Ça a toujours été ça.
Moi, j'ai des fois
l'impression d'être...
de venir parler de quelqu'un
qui aurait dû être mort.
Vous êtes
une survivante ?
Ah ouais.
Complètement !
Bah ouais !
Une miraculée !
Ah ouais,
complètement.
Complètement.
Je veux dire...
Ça,
c'est sûr et certain.
Et pour vous, ce nom, Diam's,
qu'est-ce qu'il évoque ?
À quelle femme
est-ce qu'il renvoie ?
À une femme qui,
si elle n'avait pas trouvé
la paix, serait morte.
Ça, c'est sûr, moi,
normalement, je suis morte.
Ça, c'est certain.
C'est-à-dire que
quand je raconte vraiment
que j'ai voulu
mettre fin à mes jours,
c'était sérieux, quoi,
c'est-à-dire que, vraiment,
ce que je dis souvent,
c'est que :
vous voyez, le désert,
l'image du désert ?
Quelqu'un qui avance dans
le désert et qui est perdu,
qui ne sait même plus
d'où il vient,
parce qu'il a perdu
ses repères,
il ne sait pas où il va,
parce que c'est le désert.
Il pense qu'au loin,
il y a des choses,
et en fait,
c'est des mirages.
Et il meurt de soif.
Et il est dans ce désert
et il...
Et il est seul,
il est tout seul,
il ne sait pas où aller,
mais il marche quand même.
Ben ça,
c'était moi dans la vie.
C'est-à-dire
que je marchais,
parce que ma mère,
elle voulait que je marche,
ma mère,
elle voulait pas que je meure,
mes amis voulaient pas
que je meure,
mais je marchais pour aller où ?
Pour faire quoi ?
À ce moment-là
de ma vie,
je me dis que la mort,
elle est préférable
à ce que je suis
en train de vivre.
- Vous n'avez pas donné
d'interview française
depuis 7 ans,
on vous a presque
pas entendue
depuis que vous avez arrêté
la musique il y a 13 ans
et vous avez accepté
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
pour nous présenter
ce documentaire, Salam,
qui est en séance spéciale
au Festival de Cannes.
Ce film, vous le coréalisez
avec Houda Benyamina
et Anne Cissé,
et vous le signez.
Vous y participez,
vous en êtes le sujet,
vous prenez la parole...
Pourquoi c'était important ?
Ça fait bien cinq, six ans
que régulièrement
on me contacte
pour pouvoir mettre à l'image
mon histoire
et on m'a beaucoup
demandé
de la partager
de différentes façons.
Donc, les gens venaient
avec des idées
de biopics, par exemple,
donc de films qui seraient
joués par quelqu'un,
sur mon histoire,
de fictions,
on m'a proposé des séries.
Et c'est vrai
que la plupart du temps,
quand les gens m'approchaient,
avec beaucoup
de bienveillance
et de gentillesse,
je sentais
quand même que...
C'était toujours un peu
la même chose.
C'est-à-dire
que c'était toujours l'histoire
qu'en fait, finalement,
tout le monde a
toujours racontée,
c'est, bah voilà, l'histoire
d'une jeune rappeuse
qui a...
qui a vendu beaucoup
de disques en France,
qui a été très connue,
et puis qui, ensuite,
a fait une dépression,
a été en psychiatrie
et s'est convertie à l'islam.
Voilà, c'était toujours
ce même fil,
toujours cette même histoire.
Sauf que moi, c'est pas ça.
Et je disais : mais moi, en fait,
moi, c'est pas ça, l'histoire.
Et puis, ce qu'il faut dire,
c'est que cette parole,
on vous l’a prise, aussi,
à un moment donné,
on vous l'a volée.
L'histoire, elle est...
Elle est...
Mon mari dit souvent :
Internet a une mémoire,
et la mémoire d'Internet,
c'est pas la bonne mémoire.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros,
mon histoire, c'est pas
celle qui est sur Internet,
c'est pas celle qu'on voit
régulièrement circuler.
Les gens qui ont lu
mes livres,
ils ont déjà beaucoup plus
d'informations
et je pense que ces gens-là,
quand ils m'écrivent,
ils savent que c'est pas ce
que tout le monde raconte,
mais c'est vrai que
c'est une histoire qui a été
racontée de...
de différentes façons,
mais rarement
de la bonne façon.
- Ça change quoi, de prendre
en charge son propre récit
pour soi ?
- Bah, en fait,
de base, on est venu
me demander de partager.
C'est-à-dire que
c'est pas moi,
à la base c'est pas une
initiative de ma personne,
qui me dis : ah tiens,
j'aimerais bien mettre
à l'écran mon histoire.
C'est vraiment jamais
parti comme ça.
Et puis je pense que,
très honnêtement,
j'ai aussi pris peur
que ces projets,
ils voient le jour sans moi.
Parce qu'encore une fois,
ça aurait faussé la mémoire.
Et je me suis dit :
peut-être qu'il est temps
que je puisse
partager la vérité
et puis surtout la beauté
de cette histoire.
Parce que je trouve que
c'est ça dont on parle pas,
c'est-à-dire que
pour les gens, la beauté,
c'était tout Diam's
et pas le reste,
alors que pour moi,
la beauté,
c'était Mélanie petite
qui a essayé de se construire
en tant que Diam's,
qui a pas réussi
et qui s'est trouvée après.
- Pour prendre la parole,
il fallait aussi que
vous ayez la paix en vous,
le film s'appelle Salam,
j'ai l'impression
que c'est la plus grande quête
de votre vie.
- Ouais, franchement,
je pense que toute personne
qui a connu
ce que j'ai connu,
c'est-à-dire
cette prison intérieure
qui fait sombrer
dans les maladies
psychologiques, etc.,
je pense que toute personne
qui a connu ça,
cette espèce de...
de chaos interne, cette
espèce de vide abyssal...
- De guerre, en fait.
- C'est presque...
Non, je ne dirais même pas
une guerre,
parce qu'une guerre,
il se passe plein de trucs.
Quand on est vide
et qu'on va pas bien,
il se passe
justement rien.
Et ça, c'est des choses
que les gens n'arrivent pas
spécialement à comprendre,
c'est justement : on n'arrive
pas à mettre de mots
sur ce qu'on ressent,
on est son propre bourreau,
parce qu'en fait,
les questions
qui nous harcèlent,
eh bien,
elles émanent de soi.
Et donc : à qui on va
se plaindre de soi-même ?
Enfin, c'était...
C'est vraiment une espèce
de spirale
qui est hyper complexe.
Et...
Qu'est-ce
qui me manquait ?
Beh il me manquait la paix.
Il me manquait cette
sérénité, cette quiétude,
cette paix intérieure,
en fait, tout simplement.
Je pense que c'est une quête
pour beaucoup de gens.
- Apprendre
à prendre le temps, aussi,
tout simplement ?
- Ah bah...
La paix :
d'avoir trouvé la paix
m'a permis
d'apprécier des choses,
oui, effectivement, que j'ai
l'impression parfois d'être
pas seule à partager,
parce que j'ai rencontré
des gens comme moi,
qui partagent
les mêmes choses que moi,
mais...
Je veux dire...
C'est vrai que des fois,
on a l'impression
d'être un peu différent.
Je veux dire, moi,
par exemple,
mon amour pour tout
ce qui touche à la nature,
tout ce qui touche
à ce qui nous entoure,
je sais que des fois,
c'est sujet à moqueries.
Mais moi, ça me fait sourire.
Puisque c'est
ma paix à moi,
donc tant pis
si les gens, ils...
- Vous savez, Mélanie,
on pourrait faire une interview,
là, comme ça,
questions-réponses,
confession...
C'est pas
ce qu'on va faire,
parce qu'en fait, il y a
beaucoup de réponses
dans ce documentaire.
Je vous propose
qu'on regarde un extrait
que je trouve très fort
et qu'on en parle ensemble.
- OK.
Et moi, en fait, je pense
que ce qui m'a rendue triste,
parce qu'il y a la colère
contre le fait qu'on me vole
un truc intime de ma vie,
ça, c'est clair,
mais ça, c'est gérable,
si tu veux,
ça n'a pas de conséquences.
C'est toi chez toi,
t'es un peu énervée, tu vois ?
Mais il y a surtout...
Moi, c'était vraiment
par rapport
aux gens qui m'aimaient.
Je savais
qu'ils allaient
comme briser l'amour
qu'il y avait
entre moi et le public.
C'est vraiment ça
qui m'a fait mal.
C'est vraiment de voir,
en fait,
les jauges,
tu vois, se...
se vider un peu.
Parce que c'est ça,
un peu, qui s'est passé.
C'est-à-dire que tu vends
moins de disques,
donc il y a moins de monde
dans les concerts,
mais il y a des gens,
il y a un groupe qui est là.
Et ceux-là,
à jamais, je leur serai
reconnaissante.
Et je te jure que j'en veux pas
à ceux qui ne m'aimaient
plus à ce moment-là.
Il y en a plein qui m'écrivent
aujourd'hui,
qui me disent :
ouais, je t'en ai voulu
d'avoir arrêté,
pour moi
t'étais une traître...
t'étais endoctrinée,
pour moi t'étais...
Les gens ont été
très, très durs, tu vois.
Et je ne leur en veux pas.
Je les comprends, même.
On parlait de votre public,
d'un moment de rupture
avec le public
et vous dites que ceux
qui vous ont rejetée,
ceux qui n'ont pas compris,
ceux qui ont même cru parfois
que vous étiez embrigadée,
endoctrinée,
vous ne leur en voulez pas.
Vous dites même
que vous les comprenez.
- Ouais.
Oui, parce qu'avec le temps
et avec le recul,
j'ai appris
à comprendre l'autre,
et je pense
que c'est nécessaire,
comme j'ai voulu
qu'on me comprenne.
Je pense que j'ai eu besoin
moi aussi
de comprendre les gens
et c'est vrai
qu'à ce moment-là, aussi,
la grande difficulté,
bon, j'en parle pas
spécialement dans le film,
c'est que moi, quand
je prépare ce dernier album,
j'ai vraiment l'envie de faire
de grandes choses avec Big Up,
mon association,
et donc je pense vraiment
que ça va être fédérateur,
qu'on va faire plein de trucs,
et j'imagine pas un instant
que le scandale
autour de mon voile
et de cette photo prise
à la sortie de la mosquée
va finalement tout chambouler.
- Photo volée.
Moment volé.
Secret volé !
Parce que c'était un secret
et qui devient ensuite,
après, limite,
comme je dis dans le film :
on m'accuse,
limite, de prôner ça,
alors que c'est eux
qui ont volé ce moment.
Qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites, à ce public,
à travers ce documentaire ?
Bah, très honnêtement,
je crois que j'ai pensé qu'à eux
quand je l'ai fait.
J'ai toujours pensé
qu'aux gens qui m'ont aimée.
Bon, c'est le moment
où je vais être émue,
mais il faut savoir
que ça fait 10 ans
que je suis pas
coupée du monde,
contrairement à
ce que j'entends parfois,
et j'ai des réseaux.
C'est un peu une plateforme
d'échange pour moi.
C'est-à-dire qu'en surface,
je suis pas trop là,
mais j'ai beaucoup reçu
de messages
de gens qui,
les années passant,
parce que, c'est marrant,
c'est vraiment au fil des années
que j'ai senti que quelque
chose s'était construit,
je suis devenue,
je pense,
comme quelque chose
d'important
de leur passé.
En fait, je pense que sur le coup,
les gens ne le réalisaient pas
spécialement,
moi-même, je ne l'ai
pas réalisé, je veux dire,
sur le coup, j'étais, je sais pas,
une rappeuse parmi
tant d'autres, enfin voilà !
Et en fait,
10 ans plus tard,
les gens,
ils me parlent comme si...
Enfin, comme
si on s'était connus
à un moment de leur vie
qui était important,
de construction
ou de quête, etc.
Et donc,
c'est hyper touchant,
les messages que je reçois
de jeunes filles qui
sont devenues mamans,
de jeunes hommes
qui travaillent aujourd'hui,
qui ont réussi leur vie
et qui te racontent
que quand ils étaient jeunes,
ça n'allait pas du tout.
- Et qui vous disent quoi
aujourd'hui ?
- Ils disent merci.
En fait, la plupart des gens,
ils me disent merci
et ils me disent :
si t'es heureuse,
c'est le plus important.
Mélanie, le regard des autres,
qui a tant compté pour vous,
aujourd'hui
vous en faites quoi ?
Je l'accueille avec joie,
parce que la plupart des gens
sont très gentils avec moi.
La vérité, c'est que moi,
je reçois beaucoup,
beaucoup d'amour.
Mais je ne vis plus
à travers le regard des gens.
Quand je me lève le matin,
ce n'est pas mon souci.
C'est pas mon souci,
moi, ce qui compte,
c'est que moi,
je sois bien avec moi,
avec ma famille,
avec les miens.
Et donc,
ce qui compte, c'est ça,
c'est de préserver,
en fait, cette paix.
Après, quand je rencontre
des gens dehors,
j'en parle avec
ma fille, des fois,
parce qu'elle me dit :
"Oui, les gens,
ils viennent nous voir."
Puis elle me dit :
"Ils nous coupent la parole."
Des trucs comme ça...
Et puis je lui dis :
"Ils nous aiment."
Et elle me dit :
"Oui, ils nous aiment."
Et je lui dis :
"Tu sais, l'amour,
il y a tellement de gens
qui rêvent d'être aimés,
d'être accompagnés
dans leur vie,
de pas être rejetés,
d'être compris...”
J'ai dit : “On peut pas
être mécontent
de recevoir de l'amour."
On ne va pas reparler ensemble
de cette photo volée
par Paris Match il y a 13 ans,
cette photo de vous sortant
d'une mosquée en 2009,
parce que ça a été
une telle déflagration,
une telle violence
que ce serait inutile.
Mais dans le film,
il y a quand même
cette phrase très forte
du producteur
Benjamin Ifrah qui dit :
“Ce jour-là,
comme elle l'a toujours fait
durant sa carrière,
Diam's,
malgré elle,
pose une question
à la France.”
Bon, c'est lui qui le dit.
Et je comprends
ce qu'il a voulu dire, en fait,
il dit que moi, comme, je pense,
beaucoup d'artistes,
ou comme beaucoup
de personnalités publiques,
malgré nous,
on est un thermomètre
de la société,
c'est-à-dire que
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui,
moi-même qui m'intéresse
à ce monde pour mes enfants,
je comprends un peu
ce que les jeunes,
ils aiment, etc.
Et en fait, les personnalités
aimées des jeunes,
par exemple,
sont des thermomètres
de ce que les jeunes aiment,
de ce qui les fait vibrer, etc.
Et moi,
quand effectivement
je me fais shooter
avec le voile
et qu'on voit
ce que ça suscite...
Parce que vraiment,
on se rend pas compte.
Aujourd'hui,
avec du recul,
quand justement
on a fait Salam,
on a eu accès à toutes
les archives de l'époque.
J'avais même pas réalisé
que c'était à ce point.
Je pense que
j'étais tellement déjà
accablée
à ce moment-là
que je m'en suis
pas rendu compte,
mais quand on voit
tous les articles qu'il y a eu,
et surtout la violence
et la haine
que ça a engendrées,
effectivement,
à ce moment-là,
le thermomètre,
il nous indiquait
quelque chose
qu'on n'avait
peut-être pas réalisé.
En tout cas pour moi.
- Oui, le rapport
de la France
à la religion,
le rapport de la France
à la célébrité.
Pourquoi, quand
on se tourne vers la religion,
c'est qu'on a forcément pété
les plombs, par exemple ?
Après, mon mari vous dira
que c'est l'histoire
et qu'il faut que les gens,
ils se rappellent de l'histoire
et qu'en fait, finalement,
ça a toujours été comme ça.
Ça l'était déjà avant,
bien avant que le problème
soit les musulmans.
Déjà, quand je chantais,
j'ai pas cherché
à être une icône,
j'ai pas cherché à être
un chef de file,
j'ai pas cherché...
Ça a toujours été malgré moi,
les étiquettes
qu'on me collait,
quand les gens disaient :
ah, elle est ainsi,
elle est comme ci,
elle est comme ça,
et quand je me voile,
cette nouvelle étiquette,
entre guillemets, qui arrive,
encore une fois,
c'est pas moi.
C'est pas moi qui suis venue
devant comme ça en disant :
tiens, je suis voilée,
maintenant...
Non !
J'avais pas prévu ça.
Mais j'ai été surprise, ouais.
Et je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais
une famille formidable
et des gens merveilleux
autour de moi
parce que moi,
j'avais jamais vécu
ça chez moi.
C'est-à-dire que si j'étais née
dans une famille, peut-être,
de gens pour qui
ça posait problème,
ou qui avaient un problème
avec certaines personnes
sur la Terre,
peut-être que j'aurais compris,
mais moi, à ce moment-là,
je suis surprise.
Puisque ma mère,
elle a jamais eu de problème
avec les femmes voilées,
et tout ça.
- Moi, ce qui m'intéresse,
c’est que vous soyez encore
le thermomètre
de la France aujourd'hui.
Quand votre amie,
par exemple, Vitaa,
qui est très présente
dans le film,
on comprend qu'elle
vous a accompagnée aussi,
chante Ma France à moi
sur France Inter
il y a deux ans,
quand Amel Bent,
Camélia Jordana et Vitaa
reprennent
votre morceau Marine
sur le disque Sorøre
l'année dernière,
quand même...
Vous vous dites quoi, là ?
En fait, moi,
je me dis toujours que
pour le coup,
ça ne m'appartient plus.
C'est-à-dire que vraiment,
les gens se sont approprié
ces chansons.
Moi, j'ai rien fait pour
qu'elles soient toujours là.
J'ai rien fait.
Vous ne me verrez jamais
en parler sur mes réseaux
ou essayer
de les promotionner.
Rien.
Et c'est là.
Et c'est comme ça.
C'est ce que je vous disais,
c'est que c'est les gens
qui les ont transportées
dans le temps,
je sais pas comment
on peut dire,
et moi, je suis spectatrice,
en fait,
de quelque chose
qui ne m'appartient plus.
- Quand même, cette chanson,
Marine, elle a 16 ans,
elle est toujours
d'actualité aujourd'hui...
- Il paraît !
- C'est fou !
Quand je vous dis
"ça ne m'appartient plus",
elle aurait pu être oubliée !
Je suis comme vous !
Moi, je suis spectatrice !
- Dans ce film,
et dans la vie, on le voit bien,
vous ne vous arrêtez pas.
Vous n'arrêtez pas
de penser,
d'observer,
vous dites : "Mon cerveau,
il arrête jamais de tourner,
d'essayer de comprendre.”
Vous vous êtes
jamais arrêtée ?
Non.
Il y a des gens, comme ça,
qui réfléchissent beaucoup,
il y en a qui
réfléchissent moins,
moi, je fais partie de ceux
qui réfléchissent tout le temps.
Mais c'est pas réfléchir
tout seul,
c'est ça qui est intéressant,
c'est réfléchir avec l'autre,
c'est comprendre l'autre.
- Oui, oui.
- C'est le grand défi
que lance ce film, je crois.
Vous savez, sur la religion
dont parle le film,
ce qui m'a le plus marqué,
c'est que vous en parlez
toujours au pluriel,
par exemple du fait
que toutes les grandes
religions sont liées
et que ça,
on le sait pas forcément.
On le dit pas,
on le comprend pas.
Je pense
à la surprise d'une dame
lorsque votre fille
Maryam lui dit :
"Vous pouvez aussi
m'appeler Marie."
Au début,
elle ne comprend pas.
Bah... Après, ça,
c'est mon histoire.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Moi, je m'appelle
Mélanie, Marie.
Ma mère, elle s'appelle
Dominique, Marie.
Mon père, il s'appelle
Phivos, il est grec
et il est pas
du tout musulman.
Donc toute mon histoire,
elle est dans le fait
d'apprendre à se connaître
les uns les autres,
d'apprendre à se comprendre
et surtout d'apprendre
à se respecter.
Parce que c'est pas parce
que je suis pas comme toi
que je suis contre toi.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose,
au sein de ma famille,
qui est hyper clair.
Mon oncle, c'est
un grand patron français
avec tout ce
que ça implique et tout,
on mange ensemble,
je suis voilée
et il me respecte.
Et on s'aime comme ça.
Donc, je veux dire,
mon film,
il est à l'image
de ma vie.
Ma vie entière,
c'est ça.
Moi, j'ai vécu
au milieu des gens
quand je suis partie
vivre un peu
dans la province française,
avec une voisine française,
qui avait son petit potager,
son petit cheval
et moi,
j'étais voilée,
à côté de chez elle,
et en fait,
on s'entendait hyper bien
parce qu'on se respectait.
C'est intéressant, vous dites
“on se connaît pas
les uns les autres",
pourquoi c'est si difficile
de comprendre l'autre ?
Parce qu'on n'apprend pas
à le connaître,
en fait, tout simplement,
c'est qu'on n'a pas le temps.
On n'a pas le temps.
Après, j'ai l'impression que
la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui,
quand même,
elle est...
Elle est peut-être
plus ouverte,
en tout cas plus en alerte,
parce que voilà, il y a
d'autres moyens aussi de...
J'ai l'impression qu'Internet
a fait du monde un village.
Donc c'est plus pareil, quoi.
Le monde n'est plus
aussi grand qu'avant,
c'est tout petit,
je peux voir ce qui se passe
à l'autre bout du monde
en un clic.
Donc j'ai l'impression
que, ouais,
cette jeunesse qui arrive,
elle est quand même
beaucoup plus ouverte.
C'est vrai, mais il y a aussi
dans le documentaire
cette phrase qui revient
comme un refrain :
"On se like, mais est-ce
qu'on s'aime vraiment ?"
Ouais, c'est vraiment une...
Pareil, c'est un constat
que je fais,
parce que,
comme je vous dis,
j'ai des enfants,
donc je m'intéresse
au monde
dans lequel ils grandissent
et je vois qu'aujourd'hui,
exister à travers
les réseaux, etc.,
c'est devenu
presque une quête,
c'est quelque chose
dont on doit parler
et je me dis :
ils se likent tous,
mais est-ce qu'ils s'aiment ?
Parce que c'est censé
être un "j'aime".
Mais c'est pas
un vrai "j'aime".
Est-ce que c'est
un vrai "j'aime" ?
Et c'est intéressant,
parce qu'à l'époque
où vous avez arrêté
la musique,
à l'époque de tout ce
déchaînement médiatique,
les réseaux sociaux,
ils étaient pas aussi présents.
Il y avait la haine
quand même !
Mais elle était pas
sous cette forme.
- Ça aurait donné quoi ?
- À l'époque, la haine,
c'était des courriers
qui étaient écrits à la main,
qui étaient piégés.
On avait
des courriers piégés, nous.
Ils mettaient
des lames de rasoir
dans les enveloppes
pour qu'on se coupe
quand on ouvrait l'enveloppe.
Non...
Quand je vois aujourd'hui
le déferlement de haine
qu'il y a sur les réseaux...
Après, moi,
je me sens concernée
parce que j'ai vécu
ce déferlement moi-même.
Donc...
Je l'ai vécu
à une autre échelle.
C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des gens,
ils reçoivent du harcèlement
sur Twitter,
moi, j'ai eu un harcèlement
médiatique.
Je me dis toujours que :
les gens qui parlent,
est-ce qu'ils ont conscience
des conséquences
que ça peut avoir sur
la personne dont ils parlent ?
- Vous devez être
très sensible
à toutes ces questions,
en fait.
Ça fait partie des sujets qui
me touchent le plus, ouais.
C'est-à-dire que,
vraiment, la...
Tout ce qui peut conduire
aux maladies
psychologiques,
c'est quelque chose
qui me touche beaucoup.
Vous qui avez tenu
à disparaître publiquement
ces dernières années,
quel regard
est-ce que vous portez
justement sur cette jeunesse
qui se filme,
qui se montre tout le temps,
en selfie souvent,
qui s'expose sur l'ensemble
des réseaux sociaux ?
C'est le monde d'aujourd'hui.
La question, c'est plus :
comment s'en prémunir ?
Comment faire en sorte que
ça ne nous fasse pas de mal ?
Et j'ai l'impression
que ça fait du mal
à beaucoup de gens.
Donc c'est vrai que la solution,
souvent, moi,
quand j'ai des amis
qui vivent ça,
je leur dis :
bah, ta solution,
c'est de couper !
Parce qu'en réalité,
si t'es plus là,
t'es plus une cible,
t'es plus rien,
sauf que les gens veulent
quand même exister.
Ça veut dire
qu'on existerait
seulement à travers
un écran ?
Il y a des gens, je pense,
qui n'existent qu'à travers
leurs écrans, aujourd'hui,
mais bon,
avant, c'était autre chose.
Je suis pas du tout quelqu'un
qui va penser qu'avant,
c'était différent.
Je pense juste que
c'est comme avant,
mais avec d'autres moyens.
Je veux dire, ma mère,
elle vous raconte son enfance,
j'ai l'impression
qu'elle a vécu
des trucs similaires à moi.
Sauf que c'était
sous une autre forme.
Donc voilà,
la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui,
elle est comme elle est.
C'est la jeunesse
de mes enfants.
Et moi, j'ai compris que, oui,
ma fille,
mes fils,
il faudra
qu'ils se prémunissent
parce que c'est très violent.
Vous ne vous sentez
plus jeune, vous ?
Non !
Non, je suis pas une jeune.
Ça, c'est sûr.
Surtout, quand les gens,
ils vous disent
"t'es toute mon enfance",
bon, bah...
J'ai dit : "Ah, d'accord..."
Vous écoutez
toujours du rap ?
- Non.
- Jamais ?
- Non, franchement,
je me suis
pas désintéressée
mais presque
de tout ça.
C'est compliqué
parce qu'encore une fois,
moi, mon rapport,
il est vraiment lié à l'écriture.
Moi, c'était vraiment
l'écriture, la plume,
bien plus que la musique
en elle-même.
Donc...
C'est pas ce
qui m'intéresse, voilà,
c'est pas
mon centre d'intérêt.
Vous le dites
dans ce documentaire :
"J'en ai fini avec Diam's."
Pourtant, ce film, vous le signez
“Mélanie Diam's”.
- Oui.
Bah parce que...
J'aurais aimé le signer
que Mélanie,
mais tant que je serai pas
pour les gens,
bah on rappellera
quelle Mélanie c'est.
Mais peut-être qu'un jour,
je serai que Mélanie.
- Ça voulait dire quoi,
Diam's ?
À l'époque,
c'était un petit nom
que j'avais trouvé,
moi,
en tant qu'artiste.
- C'était le diamant.
- C'était le diamant,
qui pouvait être brisé
que par le diamant.
Et...
Parce qu'un diamant peut être
brisé que par le diamant,
c'était la légende
et c'était naturel, etc.,
mais bon,
aujourd'hui je vois plus ça
comme un surnom,
en fait, que comme
un nom proprement dit.
- Ça fait combien de temps,
Mélanie,
que t'es pas revenue ici ?
- Ça fait 12 ans...
11 ans...
Mais,
forcément, j'ai l'impression,
tu sais,
de revenir dans un pays
que j'avais quitté,
que c'est...
Enfin...
C'est hyper étrange.
Tu sais, un endroit que
tu connais très, très bien,
mais dans lequel
t'es jamais revenue
et que tu regardes
de très loin.
Moi, j'aimais la scène
parce que la scène,
c'était mon rapport
aux gens.
Quand t'es un artiste qui
vend beaucoup de disques,
on ne te parle
que de chiffres, tu vois ?
On te dit :
tu es numéro 1,
tu vends 100 000,
200 000,
300 000,
c'est incroyable,
tu vends 1 million !
Mais quand tu montes
sur la scène,
tu te dis : mais là, y a
10 000 personnes ce soir,
y a 10 000
personnes demain
et puis il y a eu
50 000 personnes hier,
et puis au Cameroun,
il y a 100 000 personnes,
et au Sénégal,
il y a 20 000 personnes,
et là-bas, y a...
Tu vois, ce sont des gens !
Ce ne sont pas
des disques vendus.
Quand vous vous
retrouvez là,
il se passe quoi
dans votre tête,
dans votre corps,
vous ressentez quoi ?
En fait, ce que je me suis dit,
je me suis dit :
c'est fou, parce que
avant, la salle,
elle était pleine
et moi, je me sentais vide,
et là, je suis rentrée,
la salle était vide,
mais moi,
j'étais pas vide.
J'étais bien.
J'étais hyper apaisée,
j'étais...
J'étais bien,
j'ai même aimé ce que
ça a procuré en moi,
c'est que je suis vraiment
passée à autre chose.
C'est-à-dire que vraiment,
je regardais ça
avec beaucoup de recul,
vachement de recul.
- Vous dites que la scène,
c'était le public.
Et vous savez que le public,
il est toujours là,
ce sont des gens,
c'est-à-dire que quand
vous les croisez, aujourd'hui,
il se passe quoi,
concrètement ?
Je me souviens que j'étais
moquée à l'époque pour ça,
parce que "elle en fait trop
avec les gens”,
“elle en fait trop
avec le public”,
“elle en fait trop”...
et en fait,
moi, cet amour-là,
une grande partie
de ma vie,
il est venu panser
beaucoup, beaucoup
de plaies chez moi,
il est venu...
Il est venu mettre beaucoup
de baume à mon cœur,
et le fait de me sentir
tant aimée,
c'est quelque chose que
j'ai vraiment, vraiment,
vraiment aimé,
mais quand j'ai compris
que c'était
uniquement lié
à une carrière,
ou à une réussite
musicale,
ou à une qualité
sonore,
eh ben c'est là
que j'ai pris peur,
parce que je me suis dit :
finalement,
si demain
je fais un truc pourri,
ils seront plus là.
C'est là où tout d'un coup,
c'est un peu
comme ce que je disais,
un peu le mirage,
c'est que je me dis :
mais en fait,
cet amour-là,
il est beau, mais il est pas là
quand je vais pas bien le soir,
il répond pas
à mes questions
et puis les gens,
ils étaient plus là
quand j'étais à l'hôpital,
ils étaient plus là.
- Pourtant, dans ce film,
vous leur faites un cadeau.
Parce que ce film, Salam,
il est traversé
par un long texte
que vous avez écrit,
par vos mots, par
vos couplets, par vos rimes,
mais aussi par plein
d'images de vous,
justement en train d'écrire,
un stylo à la main.
- Ouais.
- L'écriture, quelle place
est-ce qu'elle a,
encore, dans votre vie ?
- Elle est centrale,
à ma vie,
c'est-à-dire que
j'aime vraiment écrire.
J'ai un vrai rapport
à l'écriture.
Déjà, je trouve ça beau.
Je trouve ça beau,
une plume, une feuille,
un stylo...
- Le bruit
du crayon sur le papier.
- C'est quelque chose
qui me touche.
Chacun ses sensibilités,
il y en a, ça va être
les voitures,
il y en a, c'est la cuisine,
moi, c'est ça.
Je pense que,
comme je le dis,
c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui m'apaise, voilà.
Écrire, aujourd'hui...
- C'est ça !
- Ça m'apaise.
Alors qu'avant,
c'était très destructeur.
Et vous le dites :
à un moment de votre vie,
"il aurait fallu que je crève
pour mieux écrire".
À quel moment c'est devenu
un piège, en fait ?
Bah, le piège,
il est dans le fait que...
je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont vécu ça,
beaucoup d'artistes
et peut-être même d'autres
gens dans d'autres milieux,
c'est-à-dire qu'au début,
quand on se construit,
on se construit sur une histoire
qui est très brute
et qui est forte, de base,
parce que voilà, c'est
une histoire personnelle,
c'était beaucoup
mes blessures
et tout ça et tout ça,
sauf qu'après,
tout s'arrange...
en surface.
Et donc,
vous qui vous sentiez seule,
vous êtes aimée
par des millions,
peut-être quelqu'un
qui n'avait pas d'argent,
d'un coup,
il a de l'argent,
quelqu'un qui était un bon
à rien aux yeux de tous,
finalement
il devient quelqu'un
qui a fait
une grande carrière...
Ce qu'on est à ce moment-là,
c'est une réussite,
entre guillemets,
alors que parfois,
au fond de soi ça va pas,
et cette réussite-là,
elle devient parfois
presque une prison.
Une fois que tout va mieux,
comment on écrit
des chansons tristes
si tout va mieux ?
Ben en se faisant du mal,
en fait, enfin...
Et c'était une spirale qui
était vraiment destructrice.
- C'est la question
que j'allais vous poser.
Ça veut dire quoi, pour vous,
Mélanie, réussir sa vie ?
C'est pas l'argent,
c'est pas la gloire, c'est quoi ?
Pour moi, réussir sa vie,
c'est savoir où on va,
savoir d'où on vient,
c'est réfléchir,
c'est méditer
sur ce qui nous entoure.
Et puis je pense surtout
que c'est de comprendre
le sens de cette vie.
C'est : pourquoi
je suis sur la Terre ?
Qu'est-ce que je fais là ?
D'où je viens, moi,
petit embryon ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que je suis
comme ça maintenant ?
Et qu'est-ce qui fait que
je vais forcément partir ?
Puisque c'est une réalité.
On sait très bien
qu'on va tous mourir.
Quelle est la question
que je dois me poser ?
Tu te retrouves
dans une petite salle,
une petite chambre d'hôpital,
on te confisque tout,
ton téléphone,
on te coupe du monde,
t'as pas droit
à trop de visites.
Et puis on te laisse seule
dans cette chambre.
Et puis toi,
tu te demandes :
OK, donc...
Quand est-ce que vous allez
venir m'aider ? Quoi.
Et si même les spécialistes
du cerveau
pouvaient rien faire pour moi,
je pense que dans ma tête,
j'ai un peu abandonné.
Et je me souviens
que depuis la clinique,
eh bien j'ai recommencé
à me faire du mal, en fait.
Et quand les infirmières
et les gens, ils ont vu ça,
ils ont dit :
non, ça y est, stop.
Et là...
Ben là, ils m'ont éteint.
Ils m'ont éteint.
Quand je dis “ils m'ont éteint”,
c'est qu'ils m'ont donné
plein de cachets.
Plein de cachets.
Du matin au soir,
je prenais des cachets.
Et là, je suis tombée, pour moi,
dans ce que j'appelle
l'enfer des médicaments.
C'est une spirale
qui est infernale.
Pourquoi tu pleures ?
- Parce que ça a été
une période très difficile,
très...
- Dans les larmes
de votre mère,
qu'est-ce que vous voyez ?
Quand je reparle de tout ça
avec ma mère,
je ressens ce que,
je pense,
tout plein
de jeunes ressentent
quand ils sentent
qu'ils ne brillent plus
dans les yeux
de leurs parents.
Ce que j'ai vécu,
c'est aussi ça,
c'est me retrouver
dans une situation
où tout d'un coup, on ne fait
plus la fierté des nôtres.
On est presque devenu
un problème pour eux,
malgré nous,
on est un boulet,
on est...
On est une crainte :
ma mère, elle se couchait,
elle savait pas
si le lendemain je serais là.
Et en fait,
d'avoir vécu ça
et de la voir aujourd'hui
comme ça
m'avoir acceptée
comme je suis...
Ma mère, elle m'a aimée
quand j'allais mal,
elle m'a aimée
quand j'étais connue,
quand j'étais...
sur mon lit d'hôpital après
ma tentative de suicide.
Elle m'a aimée quand
je suis revenue voilée.
Et ma mère, en ça,
elle est extraordinaire.
Elle est un exemple.
- De quoi est-ce que
vous souffriez ?
Est-ce que vous avez fini
par le savoir ?
Quel était votre mal ?
Oui, le mal,
c'était de pas savoir
ce que je faisais sur la Terre.
Quel est le but de cette vie ?
C'est ça.
C'est vraiment ça.
C'est de me demander :
mais qu'est-ce
que je fiche là ?
- Je me pose aussi
la question de l'époque,
du contexte.
Quand vous entendez,
par exemple,
Stromae parler
de ses pensées suicidaires,
de santé mentale
dans une chanson,
et quand vous voyez
comment ce témoignage a
pu être reçu aujourd'hui,
vous vous dites quoi ?
Moi, ça fait 10 ans
qu'il y a des gens
qui m'écrivent
qu'ils vont pas bien.
Je veux dire : suite,
justement, à mes écrits
et à ce que j'ai pu livrer
même par la suite
dans mes livres
et que j'ai raconté,
ce par quoi
j'étais passée,
j'ai vraiment ressenti
qu'il y a des milliers
voire des millions
de gens qui vont pas bien.
C'est une réalité.
Et là où je suis “contente”,
entre guillemets,
c'est que j'ai l'impression
que ça commence
à être pris au sérieux.
À l'époque,
c'était vraiment genre
j'étais une capricieuse,
“tu te prenais
la tête pour rien”...
- "T'es une enfant gâtée" ?
- "T'es une enfant gâtée."
Mais c'est sérieux,
les maladies mentales,
c'est pas rien.
- Au tout début du film,
on entend des réactions
de l'époque
de la fin de votre carrière,
et il y a la voix
d'une jeune fille,
ça dure 2 secondes,
ça m'a bouleversé,
qui dit "Diam's, c'est la vie."
Vous ressentez quoi,
quand vous entendez ça ?
Quand vous découvrez,
même, cette archive ?
J'ai eu envie, en fait,
qu'elle soit
dans le documentaire
parce que
je pense que c'est ça.
C'est-à-dire
qu'encore une fois,
réduire ma carrière
musicale à du rap,
c'est finalement pas
avoir compris
que moi,
j'étais juste en quête,
que ça fait partie
de ma quête
et qu'en réalité,
j'étais pleine de vie,
que je voulais justement
croquer la vie,
que je voulais pas la quitter,
que j'ai failli la quitter
et qu'au final, aujourd'hui,
j'espère être quelqu'un
qui inspire ça,
c'est-à-dire qu'après
la grande souffrance,
il y a une possibilité
de reconstruction,
de renaissance, même.
- Qu'est-ce qui
vous fait peur aujourd'hui ?
- De vous parler.
- Pourquoi moi ? Je suis
pas très impressionnant.
- Non, c'est ça : de reprendre
la parole comme ça,
de...
Parler, c'est s'exposer
à beaucoup de choses.
Le silence, c'est hyper...
C'est hyper cool.
C'était trop bien
de me taire
pendant 10 ans...
Non, mais je suis
très heureuse
de partager mon histoire,
surtout avec ceux
qui me l'ont demandé.
Je serais très contente
qu'elle aille ailleurs
et que même des gens
qui pensaient pas
pouvoir être concernés,
eh bien finalement se disent
"ah, c'est une jolie histoire".
Et la peur, elle est plus...
Non, la peur,
elle peut être de deux...
Enfin, elle peut
concerner Salam
et puis elle peut
concerner la vie.
Donc...
- Je me disais :
le monde d'aujourd'hui,
le monde dans lequel
vont grandir vos enfants,
par exemple,
il vous fait peur parfois ?
En fait, j'ai compris,
de par mon expérience,
que quoi
qu'il se passe dehors,
il faut être bien dedans.
Et en fait, ce qui compte,
c'est que mes enfants,
ils se construisent
de façon forte,
en eux-mêmes, en fait,
qu'ils soient bien
avec eux-mêmes,
dans leur tête,
qu'ils soient bien
dans leur cœur,
parce que je pense que
quand on n'est pas bien,
on n'est pas bon
avec les autres.
C'est ce qui amène
à beaucoup de colère,
beaucoup de violence.
- Je pense aussi à votre action
pour aider les orphelins,
au sein de
votre Big Up Project.
En quoi est-ce
qu'ils vous parlent,
les orphelins ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils
vous racontent, Mélanie,
qu'est-ce qu'ils
nous racontent ?
Pour moi,
un orphelin,
c'est une très,
très grande école,
parce qu'il est le miroir
de beaucoup de choses
pour lesquelles des fois,
moi, j'ai pu être ingrate,
comme le simple fait
d'avoir une famille,
d'avoir peut-être
des parents aimants,
ou pas, d'ailleurs,
mais d'en avoir.
Oui, de savoir
d'où on vient.
Et se construire, même,
peut-être avec
un parent mal-aimant,
mais c'est pas comme
de pas savoir.
Quand je suis au contact
de ces enfants,
je me dis : ils se soucient
pas de demain,
ils sont confiants.
Ils sont sereins
et les gens
qui s'occupent d'eux,
ils sont confiants
et ils sont sereins.
Pourquoi moi, je suis
si anxieuse, peut-être ?
Enfin, je parle de moi...
Là, aujourd'hui, ça va,
mais comment on peut
être parfois si anxieux ?
Avoir si peur de l'après,
alors que finalement,
il est pas entre nos mains
et qu'on contrôle pas tout ça.
- Mais comment on fait
pour se réconcilier
quand ça semble
irréconciliable ?
- Même si c'est difficile
et compliqué pour certains,
je pense quand même
que d'essayer
d'être en paix
avec les siens
et sa famille,
c'est mieux
que de faire la guerre.
Et je sais que j'ai vécu ça
avec mon père,
et aujourd'hui,
je suis très contente
d'avoir trouvé
la force de pardonner,
de passer à autre chose.
Parce qu'en fait,
c'est trop bien.
- Et quelle est
la plus belle leçon
que vous voudriez
leur enseigner,
à vos enfants ?
- À mes enfants ?
C'est que la vie,
elle a un sens.
Ils ont une grande valeur.
C'est ce que je dis
toujours à ma fille.
Je dis :
t'es un trésor,
ne laisse pas
les autres te salir,
ce monde te salir
et sois toujours belle,
sois toujours
comme une lumière,
même si les autres,
ils cherchent à t'éteindre.
Si vos enfants, un jour,
ils veulent faire
de la musique,
ils disent
"on y va, on se lance",
vous leur dites quoi ?
Je leur souhaite
mieux que ça.
Très honnêtement, je leur
souhaite mieux que ça.
Même si je sais
que c'est dur
à entendre pour certains,
non, vraiment, je leur
souhaite de se construire
sur quelque chose
qui les impliquera moins
que tout ce qui peut
toucher aux passions,
parce que des fois,
ça peut être très destructeur.
- Ils vous en parlent,
quelquefois,
de votre passé ?
- Oui, ma fille,
elle sait très bien, quoi,
elle voit bien les gens,
les gens dans la rue,
quand ils viennent me voir, etc.
Bien sûr, elle est au courant,
on en parle,
c'est l'histoire
de leur maman.
Et quand on vous dit
qu'un diamant,
c'est éternel, aussi.
Non, c'est pas éternel.
Non, non, non.
Tout ça, c'est des mythes,
du passé.
Aujourd'hui, je suis
plus trop dans ces trucs-là,
voire pas du tout, même,
mais je veux dire :
il y a rien qui restera.
Tout le monde partira.